how often do you think you lie and how
often do you think people lie to you
chances are it's much more often than
you think According to some research
married people lie to each other once
every 10 interactions while people at
the early stages of dating can lie to
their partner up to half the time you've
probably heard that Liars can be
uncovered through subtle behavioral cues
like avoiding eye contact or touching
the nose or fidgeting but the reality is
that you're more likely to spot a liar
by paying attention to what someone is
saying and how they say it so what
should you look for well Liars need to
think really hard about what they're
saying so they tend to use fewer words
and use the same words over and over
again Liars also tend to be more vague
in their answers but if you want the
truth spotting lies is no easy feat on
average people get it right around 54%
of the time basically as good as
flipping a
coin